a new study has found that more fast
food consumption is linked to anxiety
and depression now there's two
perspectives and to summarize them
really quickly perspective one is the
fast food itself and what about it could
be anything the fast food itself on some
level on a chemical physiological level
causes anxiety and depression the other
interpretation would be that there's a
correlation here but it's not actually
causative it could be
that one of the things that leads people
to eat a lot more fast food is being
socially isolated because it's easy to
go through the drive through
by yourself and then eat your food in
your car or at home which some people
might find more comfortable than going
in and sitting by themselves in a
restaurant I know people like this
and so it's actually a third factor that
is what's related to the anxiety and
depression an interesting study
nonetheless more research certainly
needed